maintenant que depuis
[Musique]
deux mois qu'est ce que tu as fait
aujourd'hui quand tu m'aimes
c'était pire que celle aurait eu alors
je ne pensais pas que ça puisse être
possible
mais alors je rassure les habitants
deviennent la ville est intacte et
elle n'a pas été détruite il ya que la
chanson
go porter sur son dos ça
[Applaudissements]
vous dit que benoît donne une dimension
plus large aux choses même juste en
fumant une cigarette c'était formidable
de le regarder juste en train de filmer
ses halles voulait bien donner une
dimension plus large là tout de suite
maintenant ça pourrait être
[Rires]
moi je suis un tout petit peu reculer
pourquoi êtes-vous dans votre chambre de
vision ce que j'ai vu que vous chercher
du regard ce qui se passait et je ne
voulais pas que vous voyez mais aurait
essayé qui m'a mis ils m'ont mis les
fiches du fait je sais si du canal sans
que cela
soit en 2008
c'est quoi
enfin c'est quoi mais attends je vais
voir je vais aller voir des matchs où je
lui demandais mon hervé là au royaume
uni 10 trusts sera nommé premier
ministre aujourd'hui chose rare la
passation de pouvoirs avec son
prédécesseur boris johnson se fera en
écosse au château de balmoral et non au
palais de buckingham résidence de la
reine à londres ça n'était pas arrivé
depuis
1885 un changement de protocole lié à
l'état de santé d'elizabeth 2 qui limite
ses déplacements
libres dans
ce pays
c'est un spectacle magique relayée par
le compte twitter de liesse ces images
des aurores australes ont été captées
depuis la station spatiale
internationale
alors située à 400 km de la terre au
dessus de l'océan indien cette lumière
verte est la conséquence de la collision
de particules solaires avec le champ
magnétique de la terre l'astronaute
américain bob heinz a filmé cette
séquence mi août elle a été mise en
ligne hier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hervé hervé ça va mon chéri s'cusez moi
non alors
alors
[Applaudissements]
c'est qu'à vous seront psy je vois pas
d'accord donc ça charrie les 26 cas
c'est charrie les vêtements à sa charge
dirk et ballets et ben tu sais quoi et
ben laisse moi te dire que tu as
le célèbre animateur yann barthès je
pense que vous connaissez confie que la
notoriété l'a rendu agoraphobe alors
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas c'est
quelque chose de très pénible avec
lequel il faut vivre au quotidien quant
à l'agoraphobie c'est avoir peur des
gens
hervé montsouris en fait je crois que
j'étais fiche je me dis je comprenais
rien c'est
je trouve moi j'aimerais bien marquer
suleman dont souleymane sarr gars de
chez moi c'est qu'ils souleymane c'est
gilles verdez m'acheter du faux pas ce
soir on joue pas ce soir bon bah tiens
je te donne tu écris merci pour match à
mon chéri y'en a expliqué que parfois
certaines personnes voulaient je cite
lui mettre son poing dans la figure mais
il a ensuite rajouté ceci il ferait de
buxeuil
donc vous êtes prévenus attention yann
fait de la boxe thaï alors c'est de la
boxe de très petite taille mais quand
même offert une bonne saucisse faut que
la viande soit très froides quand on
lâche
c'est beaucoup plus facile pour fourrer
la saucisse mais voilà après la chauffer
l'attendre petit à petit
c'est très important
c'est un thème qui m'inspire beaucoup
mais beaucoup plus de blagues titre 7
c'est bon pas
battu ni ce combat ce qui ciblent pas
ce qu'on allait faire la vidéo il est où
mon téléphone
annonçait secousses assez les secrets de
mars assez pour faire du sport mais avec
des fous là
c'est marseille dd
paraît correct c'est pas très tendu j'ai
pas envie cas de gaza je sens que ça
vient toutes les petites soir de doigté
non mais là vraiment je suis entrain de
n'est pas t'es quoi elle est d'un fort
beau calibre je tiens à préciser
c'est celle de traces sur le bois
tom cruise veut surtout montrer qu'à 60
ans il reste un cascadeur hors pair
cette séquence aujourd'hui mise en ligne
avait été réalisée en avril pour une
avant-première de top gun ou l'acteur ne
pouvait se rendre tom cruise se justifie
il tournait alors le nouveau mission
impossible réalisé par christopher
mcquarrie à ses côtés dans les airs les
futures aventures d'ethan hunt s'annonce
spectaculaire mais il faudra être
patient sortie au cinéma prévue en
juillet 2023